that boris johnson announced that that
actually comes in on monday
it could look at uh introducing vaccine
passports that's one of the most
politically tricky things this
government could do but they always held
that option in reserve now vaccine
passport is where you have to prove that
you've had probably two jabs still
in order to get into some venues
outdoors and indoors
in order to show that you are protected
it's not clear yet how that works uh how
that system of certification works with
the booster however so perhaps boris
johnson will set that out and then the
third area that i would expect boris
johnson to talk about is whether or not
there are going to have to be additional
requirements to wear
masks in certain settings now
last
weekend
really two weekends ago we had boris
johnson say
that he wanted people to wear masks on
public transport and on shops in england
of course that was already the
requirement
in scotland and other parts of the
united kingdom but i think boris johnson
has been discussing with colleagues
whether or not they might have to go
further on that uh and we could see uh
there has been a discussion about
whether or not uh masks might have to be
uh introduced in schools but i think
there's been a lot of pushback from
members of the cabinet on that so not
quite sure that that will get over the
line but that's the kind of thing that
they've been discussing
over the last 36 hours in government
members of covido which is the inner
sanctum of cabinet ministers that
discuss and decide on covid measures uh
has been uh was meeting early afternoon
there was a cabinet call around about
four o'clock in which cabinet ministers
were giving the brief readout of what
the prime minister was going to say uh
and uh roughly three minutes past six
boris johnson uh will stand up to make
the announcements that he didn't think
he was going to have to make at this
stage he hoped uh he wasn't going to
have to review coveted restrictions
until roundabout december the 18th uh
but that has been brought forward by
several days uh because the data coming
out of south africa which i'll suspect
we'll see
on slides from chris witte and patrick
valent in the next few moments has been
worse when it comes to transmission in
other words
omicron the new variant of coronavirus
is spreading faster uh through
communities more easily uh through the
population meaning that there is uh the
scientists and prime minister will argue
a risk of more people ending up in
hospital and therefore action is needed
in order to stop the nhs uh being
overwhelmed that has always been the
point uh uh the uh idea and the uh
thrust of public policy when it comes to
coronavirus to stop the nhs being
overwhelmed uh but of course the context
as you know mark is it all comes on a
very difficult political day for the
prime minister yeah and i mean that is
the question isn't it how on this day
the public will feel about being told of
new restrictions will they follow new
restrictions if the old ones weren't
being followed by downing street
staff
december the 18th uh 2020 was the day
that of course we've all been talking
about uh because that was the day where
danny street staff
largely officials some political
advisers are meant to have got together
uh in downey street for an evening of
entertainment parties uh and games it
was first revealed by the daily mirror a
week ago today the prime minister
announced an inquiry into it danny
street no longer say it didn't happen
but they say that simon case the cabinet
secretaries instead has launched an
investigation to find out exactly what
went on and we saw the resignation of an
aide who joked about such a party
allegra stratton uh earlier this
afternoon now the fact that boris
johnson both introduces the rules and
that
his aides apparently allegedly break the
rules has been concerning conservative
mps listen to this select committee
chair william rag about his worries on
that subject
there are media reports of a cabinet
meeting and press conference this
afternoon to initiate covered winter
plan b without reference to this house
covert passes will not increase uptake
of the vaccine but will create a
segregated society
is my right honourable friend the prime
minister aware that very few will be
convinced by this diversionary tactic
the government rejects any suggestion
that uh the announcement of uh further
uh additional restrictions is in some
way a diversionary tr uh tactic uh from
the political horror show frankly that
we've had of the last 24 hours however
there was a discussion yesterday morning
at boris johnson's cabinet
and many of the several other cabinet
ministers at that meeting slightly
surprised that restrictions coming so
quickly off the back of that discussion
because they didn't feel that uh
measures would be needed quite so
quickly
figures like michael gove suggesting
something needed to be done then but few
expecting that boris johnson would push
the button on that as soon as 24 hours
later with a press conference
today now that does mean that boris
johnson will face lots of difficult
questions in that press conference about
whether or not his staff had a party in
the consequences he will try and back
those off by saying that he's uh
initiated an independent inquiry if you
can say that an inquiry by the cabinet
secretary is indeed independent given he
works very closely uh with the prime
minister um difficult questions too
because allegra stratton his aide uh who
resigned in the last couple of hours uh
gave an emotional and forceful statement
on the steps of her house choosing to go
out there and face the cameras in time
for the evening bulletins but declined
to say that the party didn't take place
it was entirely open to her to deny that
this party happened but she didn't that
will put more pressure uh on the prime
minister as you've been reporting today
mark uh nine percent of the public
appear to believe downing streets and
boris johnson uh that no party took
place uh everybody else either says they
don't know or think that something did
go uh uh go on in downing street that
broke the law and the boris johnson
wasn't telling the truth that is what
worrying conservative mps um douglas
ross the leader of these scottish
conservatives suggesting that the big
problem here is that the prime minister
misled the house of commons
and suggested that if he was in a
government role uh at the moment he
would resign over this because he
couldn't defend the government's uh
stance on it but uh
boris johnson likely to back that up
back that uh back that off suggest that
you need to wait for the independent
inquiry by simon case to find out
exactly
what happened
earlier today there was a briefing by
the prime minister's spokesman
and
other prime ministerial spin doctors
where they came under fire because the
terms of that simon case inquiry are
only about december the 18th but you'll
have been reading in the newspapers
hearing on sky news there are other
dates where there are allegations of
parties in number 10
downing street that took place last
winter at times where restrictions would
have prohibited them some took place uh
in the downing street official areas
where people work some are alleged to
have taken place in the private flat
belonging to boris johnson and his wife
carrie johnson
mrs johnson denies that any uh such
gatherings took place
but there isn't an independent inquiry
into any of those the focus of this
inquiry is just on what happened on that
evening of december the 18th but but you
said it's not an independent inquiry
there's also not as far as we know a
criminal inquiry is that right
so the metropolitan police put out a
statement again last night in light of
the leaked footage saying they don't
routinely investigate historic uh
coveted restriction
accusations i mean in some senses all
crimes are historic so
it's a slightly odd statement but they
said they would review the footage and
take it into account
the prime minister at prime minister's
questions agreed to kiss dahmer's
proposition that he'd hand over
everything to the metropolitan police
involved in this inquiry but afterwards
that uh commitment would seem to be
slightly watered down by his aides who
simply said that anything that the
metropolitan police asks for they would
hand over so at this stage it's not
clear uh what if anything is going to
the police and what the police will do
about it
okay sam uh let's break off there
because we're waiting for this uh news
conference but we're gonna go first to
the commons uh sajid javid is uh on his
feet health secretary so we're just
gonna have a listen into what uh he's
saying
and i'd like to update the house on the
latest developments
mr speaker there are three reasons why
the omicron variant is a threat
the first
is that it's far more transmissible than
the delta variant
the delta variant was much more
transmissible than the alpha variant and
we're confident that omicron is
significantly more transmissible than
delta
we can see this most starkly when
looking at how many days it takes for
the number infections to double for each
variant
for delta this was around seven days
but for omicron based on the latest data
from here and around the world
our latest analysis is that it's been
around
it's a between two and a half and three
days
mr speaker
and uh
straight from the commons to downey
street as soon as we learned of the new
omicron variant this government acted
introducing targeted and proportionate
measures as a precaution whilst our
scientists discovered more and were
learning more every day
we don't yet know omicron's severity its
exact rate of transmission nor indeed
the full effectiveness of our vaccines
against it
but since i last spoke to you it's
become increasingly clear
that omicron is growing much faster than
the previous delta variant and it's
spreading rapidly all around the world
568 cases have been confirmed through
genomic sequencing across every region
of the uk
and the true number is certain to be
much higher
most worryingly there is evidence that
the doubling time of omicron in the uk
could currently be between two and three
days
and while there are some limits on what
we can learn from south africa
because of the different
rates of vaccination different rates of
previous infection we're seeing
growth in cases here
in the uk that now mirrors the rapid
increases previously seen in south
africa
and south africa is also seeing
hospitalizations roughly doubling in a
week
meaning that we can't yet assume that
omicron is less severe than previous
variants
so while the picture may get better and
i sincerely hope that it will we know
that the remorseless logic of
exponential growth could lead to a big
rise in hospitalizations therefore sadly
in deaths
and that's why
it's now the proportionate and the
responsible thing to move to plan b in
england while continuing to work closely
with our colleagues in the devolved
administrations so we slow the spread of
the virus
by ourselves the time
to get yet more boosters into arms and
especially in the older and more
vulnerable people
and understand the answers to the key
outstanding questions about omicron so
first
we will reintroduce the guidance
to work from home
guidance to work from home employers
should use the rest of the week to
discuss working arrangements with their
employees but from monday you should
work from home if you can
go to work if you must but work from
home if you can alright i know this will
be hard
for
for many people but by reducing your
contacts in the workplace you will help
slow transmission
second from this friday we will further
extend the legal requirement to wear a
face mask to most to most public indoor
venues including theatres and cinemas
there will be of course exceptions where
it's not practical such as when eating
drinking exercising or singing
third we'll also make the nhs covered
pass mandatory for entry into nightclubs
and venues where large crowds gather
including
unseated indoor venues with more than
500 people
unseated outdoor venues with more than 4
000 people
and any venue with more than 10 000
people
the nhs
coveted pass can still be obtained with
two doses but we will keep this under
review as the boosters roll out
and having taken clinical advice since
the emergence of omicron a negative
lateral flow test will also be
sufficient
as we set out
in plan b
we will give businesses a week's notice
so this will come into force
in a week's time
helping to keep these events and venues
open at full capacity while giving
everyone who attends them confidence
that those around them have done the
responsible thing to minimize risk
to others
as omicron spreads in the community we
will also introduce daily tests for
contacts instead of isolation
so we keep people safe while minimizing
the disruption to daily life
and of course we will take every step to
ensure our nhs is ready for the
challenges ahead
but the single biggest thing that every
one of us can do is to get our jabs and
crucially to get that booster as soon as
our turn
arrives
one year to the day since the uk became
the first country in the world to
administer a coveyed vaccine into the
arms of margaret keenan we've opened up
the vaccine booster to all those over 40
and we're reducing the gap between
second dose and booster to a minimum of
just three months
our heroic nhs staff and volunteers have
already done almost 21 million boosters
including reaching 84 of all the
eligible over 80s
but we need to go further and faster
still
because our scientists are absolutely
confident that your immune your immune
response will be stronger if you've been
boosted and while you're at it please
get your flu jab too
let's do everything we can to protect
ourselves and our loved ones this winter
and to reduce the pressures on our nhs
as we learn more so we will be guided
by the hard medical data around four key
criteria
the efficacy of our vaccines and our
boosters the severity of omicron
the speed of its spread and the rate of
hospitalizations
we will constantly
monitor
the data
and keep it under review and of course
we must be humble in the face of this
virus
but if and indeed as soon as it becomes
clear that the boosters are capable
of holding
this omicron
variant
and we've boosted enough people to do
that job of keeping omicron in
equilibrium then we will be able to move
forward as before so please everybody
play your part and get boosted i'm now
going to hand over to chris to do the
slides thank you prime minister uh first
slide please
uh i wanted to situate this uh initially
on where we are with delta because
what's happening is omicron is coming on
the back of a still high rate of delta
transmission and hospitalization
so in the first slide what we have is
the number of people testing positive
for covid in the uk
and that has been drifting upwards not
at a very rapid rate but it has been
drifting upwards
the omicron data aren't really going to
be visible in this
for a few days but they will become
visible over time
next slide please
the number of people in the hospital
with kovid in the uk
has uh because of the booster
vaccination program in particular uh
been drifting down uh until this point
in time with the numbers going into
hospital uh reducing although that's now
stabilized slightly
and that's really because the boosters
are particularly going to protect and
are protecting people who are in the
highest risk categories as the prime
minister has said
next slide please
and the number of people in the uk who
are dying uh has again gradually been
decreasing over time but uh is still uh
a daily average
of 121 deaths from covid
so we still have a significant issue
with covid and i think anybody who
speaks to anyone working in the nhs
would say that is on top of an
incredibly busy system
next slide please
in terms of our main major counter
measures of course the biggest one as
the prime minister has said is boosting
and this is steadily increasing so we
now have over a third of those who are
eligible have already had a booster and
they are by and large the most
vulnerable uh third but there's still
people who are in uh in higher risk
groups have not been boosted uh and of
course we have to move down those groups
and that is going to become absolutely
critical we think uh as we move on to
into a period where omicron becomes
significant and probably then becomes
dominant
next slide please
and if this is a just a data data just
to
show
quite how effective with the variance
we've had to date vaccination can be and
what it compares is in the dark lines
the hospitalization rate
in the the blue black bars
in those who are
unvaccinated
and in the uh orange bars those who are
vaccinated with two doses this is uh
largely protecting against delta
but as you can see at every age
a really substantial improvement
in your protection
next slide please
so now we move on to the data on omicron
and these are data probably people have
seen versions of in
in media over the last few days but i
think they do need uh point needs sort
of uh flashing out a bit
so these are the number of people
testing positive for covert 19 in south
africa at this point in time the big
increase in kovid in south africa is
virtually all
the omicron variant
and this is now spread all around south
africa and as you can see this is an
incredibly steep
increase
in rates
and we're now seeing this translating
into increasing increases in
hospitalization so for example i was
talking to some of my colleagues from
south africa this afternoon and they
were saying that uh informal data still
to be uh still to be uh added to but
there was around about a 300
percent increase on hospitalizations uh
over the last week
uh so um some of those will have come in
with
uh omicron and some of them will come in
as a result of omnicron uh but the fact
is those numbers are going up very
sharply
next slide please
so what's happening here in the uk well
i'm afraid that the data here are now
clear
what you can see here
is the number on the left and on the
right the percentage
of cases with a with what's called s
gene target failure this is a marker for
omicron virtually all the cases now
who've got this marker will have omicron
a very small number at the bottom will
not
and as you can see whether you look at
the absolute count or the percentage
this is going up incredibly fast now
and as the prime minister has said this
is doubling at this point in time it may
slow down and the aim of the measures
announced by the prime minister is is to
slow things down but it's doubling
currently between two and three every
two and three days
that is an extraordinarily fast rate and
you therefore can get with very small
numbers
to very large numbers really quite
quickly
now the question obviously people
reasonably want to ask is will this feed
through to people in hospital and how
quickly
and i think i'd just like to
just point out two realities
first of all uh the first one is a good
one but the moment the spread is in
younger people who would you would not
expect to go into hospital and is once
it starts moving up the ages and into
vulnerable groups that you'll start to
see that so there will be a lag as it
moves into more vulnerable groups
and then we know from previous ways and
this is not particularly surprising that
there is a delay between people becoming
infected with covid and ending up with
symptoms and then with hospitalization
so there's usually about a two week
delay we would therefore not expect
that these cases that the case rates in
hospital will start to go up for a
number of probably two to three weeks
and in that period if you're doubling up
at the speed we're talking about now we
move from very small numbers to really
substantial numbers and it will keep on
doubling
and that really is the reason
why these measures have been announced
by the prime minister as agreed by uh
ministers today
thank you very much thanks very much
chris uh patrick anything you want to
add
okay good uh well let's let's go to
members of the public uh then dave from
chester
our mandatory vaccinations being
considered likely on the eu and other
global nations and if not why
why is it acceptable to put measures on
our freedoms but not that on our
vaccination statuses
thanks dave well i said right at the
beginning of this pandemic that uh
i think or as soon as we were really
talking about vaccinations seriously uh
that i didn't want us to have a society
in a culture where we force people to
get vaccinated i don't think that's ever
been the the the way we do things in
this country and actually dave we've
been able to achieve uh through the
volunteerism of the british people
through their incredible public
spiritedness willingness to roll up
their their sleeves and get vaccinated
uh huge numbers huge proportions of our
of our population i think that uh there
is going to come a point if we can uh if
we can show that the uh the vaccines are
capable of of holding the uh of omicron
uh and that's the the key thing that i
think that we need to to test well i do
think that we're going to have to have a
a conversation about uh ways in which we
uh we deal with this uh pandemic because
i want to be absolutely clear with you i
don't believe we can keep going
indefinitely
with
non-pharmaceutical
interventions i mean restrictions on
people's way of life
where just because uh a substantial
proportion of the population still sadly
has not got uh vaccinated and i think
we're going to need to have a national
conversation about the the way forward
and
uh and the other things that we can do
to protect those who are hard to reach
who haven't got vaccinated for one
reason other who may have medical
reasons why they can't get vaccinated
other ways of of protecting them
but that is a stage that i think we will
come to if and when uh we establish uh
as i hope that we will
that the uh the booster is effective
against omicron and the booster is
capable of of holding omicron getting us
back into that uh equilibrium uh the the
double jabs uh got us into uh with uh
with delta if if you if you follow me so
uh it's at that moment i think we will
have to talk seriously about uh moving
on uh from uh the way we
from thinking about further uh further
npis and and uh thinking about other
ways in which we we protect people uh
rachel from essex
rachel asks why can't fully vaccinated
british travelers stuck in red-listed
countries self-isolated home uh when
they return instead of a hotel
quarantine hotels are too expensive
especially as this was implemented at
short notice not giving travelers a
chance to to get home well uh rachel i
think that's a very fair challenge i
think that uh given the way omicron is
now seeded around the world and and not
just in in red listed countries i think
we we will be looking at the
the red list and the way that we uh we
do it but uh it's it's been very
important in the immediate period of the
immediate response to omicron to have
very tough border measures uh to slow
the arrival of the
of the variant
the objective of chris pratt really
wanted to add to
that okay then let's go straight to
laura koonsburger bbc
news
thank you very much prime minister
you're tightening the rules again for
millions of people tonight
how can you stand at that lecture and
exactly where some of your team laughed
and joked about covert rules and tell
people they must now
follow your new instructions and are you
really asking the public to believe that
you had no idea what was going on under
your own roof
uh
actually the first thing i want to say
thanks very much laura first thing i
want to say is that
i know that today
allegra stratton has resigned and i and
i wanted to uh to pay tribute to
her because she has been uh in in spite
of what
uh everybody has seen and uh uh and
and again i mean i make no excuses for
uh the frivolity with which the the
subject was handled uh in that uh in
that rehearsal uh that people saw in
that clip
and there could be no excuse for it and
it was it was uh i can i can totally
understand how infuriating it was but i
want to say that allegra has been
a fine colleague has achieved a great
deal uh in her time in government and
was a particularly effective spokesman
for cop 26 she coined uh the the coal
cars cash trees agenda and helped ready
to to to marshall and and to rally the
the world behind the agreement in cop uh
26 and uh i i really laura you forgive
me i wanted to to say that because i
think it's been a you know a sad day for
her as well uh as an infuriating uh
event for many many people around the
around the country and on that on that
point uh look i just want to i want to
repeat that the the fundamental point is
that
i think
the
the the british public
um
notwithstanding the the point that you
make can see the vital importance of the
medical information
that we're giving
and they can see the need
to
take it
to heart and and to act upon it and that
point has been proved time and time
again
and it's never been more conspicuous in
the way that the public has responded to
the uh the vaccine rollout and the way
that they've uh they've done the
responsible things so
i'm i'm i i take my encouragement uh
from the way uh the public have have
dealt with it themselves um anushka
astana of of itv
prime minister you've only really agreed
to an investigation into what happened
on december the 18th last year because
of the video that emerged from this room
and allegra stratton's resignation seems
to further suggest that a party took
place despite the denials but we've also
had serious allegations about parties on
three other occasions so i want to ask
you why they aren't being investigated
is it because you haven't been caught
out in those cases or is it because
reports are true that you attended some
of them and to
the rest of you here can i ask how
worried you are about whether this
undermines public trust because the
polling suggests that it does do and
conservative mps are openly saying that
it's very hard now to mandate
the public to act
thanks very much anushka well i repeat
what i said uh in the house and uh uh
earlier today uh the the cabinet
secretary uh will uh conduct an an
inquiry into the uh
into what took place on december the
18th uh as for other events that uh uh
other dates that you mentioned
as far as i'm aware the best of my
knowledge uh
and we have followed the rules
throughout and that is that is uh what
you would expect indeed we followed the
rule as far as i'm aware uh the rules
were followed on december the 18th as
well and uh you know i just i just
repeat that point but uh it's clearly
important that the cabinet secretary is
able to get to the bottom of it but in
the meantime on your you know your your
sort of glo your global your big point
again uh anushka which is really the
same as as laura's i think the
overwhelmingly the the public see uh the
importance of the uh the messages that
they are getting via this uh medium it
is imperfect uh we do what we can to
explain uh what we think is is necessary
uh i know it's contentious i know it's
difficult and i know that sometimes the
messages are confusing uh we do our
absolute best to make it as clear as
possible and we do everything that we
can uh to protect public health that's
what we're uh we're uh we're driven by
but uh chris and patrick you were also i
mean the measures work because people
follow them and that's been shown time
and time again during this it's
incredibly important everyone follows it
it's everybody it's was incredibly
important throughout it's going to be
incredibly important going forward
um and it only works if we all do it
and
we're now facing um a viral variant
that's rapidly progressing it's got a
doubling time of between two and three
days
and measures need to be taken to try and
slow the spread of that variant as well
as and i think this is important
us all boosting our own defenses by
getting a booster jab so i think you
know the rules are there quite carefully
thought through and given scientific
evidence and they're there because
they're important and they're there for
everybody to stick to
yeah if i can just add to that i mean i
think
you know we all know that people get
very angry
including colleagues and friends and
when they feel that it's unfair
and our prime minister said that in
house commons and he's said it today
that's quite different from people uh i
think wanting to actually know what's
going on
and then make decisions and i think
those two need to be separated and the
point about what we're trying to do is
trying to actually say look here are the
reasons this is moving very fast
doubling every two to three days it is
too early for us to be absolutely
confident about hospitalizations but i
think
you've seen how things have gone before
that's probably the way to bet and then
if we're pleasantly surprised no one
will be happier than
than i would be and patrick and the
prime minister
and um we know that
it looked as if he was going to be able
to evade uh
vaccination and now clinically we know
that it can in terms of infection so we
know that is an issue therefore the
boosters become significantly more
important
and we know that we're going early now
so as to try and be able to slow this
down at an early stage of events and i
think if it's laid out to people in a
way that is reasonable
irrespective of other things people want
to know the logic as to why they're
doing it and i hope we're trying to lay
out the logic of trying to do that
that's not in any way to try and move
away from the earlier point but i just
think those two should be kept separate
in people's minds
thanks very much chris beth rugby sky um
prime minister on allegra strassen's
resignation she resigned today she
looked broken as she did it how did you
feel
when you watched that statement
and watched what she said heard what she
said
and doesn't it lead to your leadership
being questioned
if others are taking responsibility for
things that happen in this place instead
of you taking responsibility and to the
scientists people are going to feel
pretty flat today listening to this
press conference they were told to get
their jobs to get their boosters that we
would have an irreversible path out of
lockdown that life would continue
winter comes
we are now being told that we have to
live with restrictions again is this
just the reality of living with covid so
this this is not just another year this
is happening but this is our lives now
for years to come i think people will be
worried about that thank you
yeah so just for beth first on your
first point look yeah i repeat what i
said to
to laura i think that allegra has been
an outstanding uh spokesperson for
uh for the government for cop uh she did
she did an extraordinary job and i'm i'm
very very sorry to to lose her and on
your point about responsibility i didn't
just take responsibility for things that
happened in this uh in this in this
building uh i take responsibility for
everything that happens in this in this
government and i've made i've made that
clear throughout the pandemic
on the um
question about
where we are now what that means for the
future
this virus has mutated a lot quickly
and
that is sort of what you'd expect at
this stage that you start to see more
mutations
this one's got a lot more than anyone
thought would arrive that quickly
and that's what's caused so many
concerns about it spreading very fast
the good news is that
so far it looks as though when you get
very high antibody levels with the
booster vaccine it's definitely having
some effect against it in the laboratory
studies we need to watch and see what
happens over the next few weeks as we
get more data on that so the boosters
remain incredibly important as a way of
increasing immunity
what we're on is a road from
pandemic to endemic where this becomes a
more sort of regular infection like flu
or something over time but we're in a
sort of bumpy transition for that and
that's going to be difficult and it is
difficult now and there are special
measures that need to happen now to try
and reduce the spread it doesn't mean
this is what happens in perpetuity
you would expect that over time this
becomes a virus which then has
peaks every year just in the way that
flu does perhaps
but it wouldn't be endlessly having new
variants that always escape
escape vaccines to some extent you would
also expect that the vaccine will need
to change over time just as the flu
vaccine changes year on year and you get
a slightly different one because the
thing continues to evolve a bit so i
think this is a
surprise change that's happened it's a
big one and yes it's going to make
everyone feel a bit sort of deflated
about it but there are things that can
be done i think the vaccines are going
to hold up to some extent here and i
think probably boosters will really push
that to a level that's going to be
important we need to test that and find
out and i don't think it's a harbinger
of what happens here after we may see we
will see more variants
and they will always cause some sort of
challenge but that challenge is the same
sort of challenge that you're going to
see year on year with other things as
well
over time
can i just add to that because i mean i
obviously completely agree
um we're in a transition period from the
point uh when we when the pandemic first
hit
in 2020 where we had to rely entirely on
social medias and had no medical
countermeasures
we will get to a stage where we have
multiple countermeasures probably lots
of different types of vaccines
antivirals we currently don't a whole
variety of others which is the way we
have dealt now with very many infectious
diseases we're in that mid point
we are immeasurably better off now than
we were with the vaccines we've got with
drugs with better hospital treatments a
whole bunch of things that are so much
better than they were
it would be much quicker getting over
this than it would have been if we the
same situation had hit us a year ago but
we shouldn't at no point if we said that
there wouldn't be new variants
significant ones potentially and vaccine
escape ones that said that's been said
by almost every i suspect every media
outlet that's uh represented here
repeatedly and for good reasons that's
the biological uh inevitability now when
it comes to this particular in the long
run i think the outlook is
good but i think we have to accept that
it's not it is still a difficult period
and in terms of this particular variant
the question i think is really going to
be is this held by the current vaccines
with
boosters or are we actually going to
have to do a reformulation of the virus
the vaccine at least for more vulnerable
people uh and that that is what we will
need to do uh over time and it may be
actually what we have is a transition
period where
the booster holds it for a bit and that
buys us time and then we can actually
get a specific or what's called
polyvalent vaccine and that will allow
us then to in you know from later on in
this year be able to respond to it
directly so i think we should in a sense
what i think we should say is i can see
why people would feel deflated but this
is a kind of setback this is not a this
is not a situation we're back to square
one we are we're kind of we're having to
just deal with it as we always thought
we might have to
follow up quickly you said that you were
furious about the video you saw
about the mock press conference yes
how did you feel when you saw
electricity i'm sorry i'm sorry because
of the
of the
the huge uh
press of of uh meetings so far today i i
haven't been able to uh to see that i'm
of course aware of what uh allegra has
has said and i i i i just repeat what i
what i said i'm very grateful to her for
everything that she's uh that she's done
and
uh i i i wish her uh all the very best
and and and we will certainly miss you
miss her uh here here in government but
i just want to add to uh to what what
chris has said on um this this this
crucial period because i think that uh
there is a there is a
at least of a strong possibility uh that
we will uh discover in the course of the
next few uh days and weeks that
indeed the the combination of uh of two
jabs and a booster is capable of holding
omicron in uh in equilibrium in the way
that uh we want and and then as as i
said we will be able uh to move forward
and it's always worth bearing in mind
that what we're doing today
uh with plan b is something that we we
set out uh back in september so this is
not a a deviation from uh what we the
position that we thought we might find
ourselves in as as winter uh winter set
in uh we always reckon that you would
we'd see a spike in uh in disease and um
and in infection uh actually delta has
been remarkably stable uh the problem uh
has been the sudden emergence of omicron
and the real spike uh that it's
producing and and given the potential
numbers that omicron could produce uh we
just have to respond uh today in the in
the way that we are uh pippa crew are
from the mirror
thank you prime minister i thought i'd
have another goat anushka's question
because i don't think he quite answered
it
um can i ask why you've asked simon case
why you've tasked simon case with
investigating a party on the december
the 18th last year that you weren't at
rather than one on november the 27th
where you gave a speech
that you were at in breach of the rules
by any reasonable legal analysis and
further to that will you extend the
inquiry some cases inquiry to include
any other gatherings events parties use
the term that you choose that took place
in number 10 or indeed in your flat
if there's evidence of them
so first of all uh um pippa on the there
this is a a a huge as people know this
is a massive department of state and
there are people working flat out uh the
whole time uh working on all sorts of
of issues and they they work they work
extremely hard and uh
i according to
very very well respected uh civil
servants and uh advisers special
advisors that i've talked to about what
happened uh in the events that uh
that you described uh no rules were
broken uh i've asked simon case to uh to
look at the other cabinet secretary
simon case to look at
the uh the december the 18th event i'm
sure he'll be uh considering uh all
sorts of things but as far as i'm
concerned all the evidence i can see is
that uh
people in this building have stayed
within the rules if that turns out not
to be the case
and people wish to bring uh allegations
to uh to my attention or to the to the
police or whoever then of course uh
there will be a proper sanctions uh but
in the meantime i think what we should
do is uh let simon get on with uh let's
the cabinet secretary get on with his
job and i'm sure he'll be uh making his
findings public as soon as possible
ben
are you are you restricting him to
looking at december the 18th i mean
that's that's the
question the guidance has been the and
the rules have been observed at all
times and uh he's looking at the uh the
issue of the 18th of december he may
wish to look at other things that's a
matter frankly for for him uh ben reilly
smith of the telegraph
thank you prime minister three quick
ones tory and peace have suggested you
pulled this announcement forward to
bounce headlines about the christmas
party is that true uh on christmas
parties and nativities what's your
message now to the country is that those
should be cancelled
and there's no time limit at all to
these new restrictions or when they
might be considered when do you think
the earliest point that might be
mid-january february or spring
and a quick one for professor witty just
picking up on your point about
reformulating the vaccines do you think
there's a real possibility a lot of
people might need a fourth vaccine
before next autumn to counter omicron
right thanks very much ben so look on
the on the first point we'll just
imagine the counterfactual um you know
colleagues say uh or people say that um
we're somehow making this announcement
to coincide with uh events in in
politics well actually uh imagine if uh
this step were to have been delayed uh
because of uh political uh uh uh events
of one kind or another what would people
say then uh
you've got to act uh to protect public
health uh when uh you've got the clear
evidence and uh i think it was i think
i'm right in saying that sage only met
yesterday
to discuss this uh the the evidence
about the transmissibility of the
viruses uh we've been watching it for
days but it's become i'm afraid
unmissable not just in south africa but
in this country as well and
you know if you if you delay
uh as everybody knows with a doubling
time of two and a half to three days uh
you see uh more doublings and your
position becomes uh predictably uh and
inevitably
worse and more difficult to to recover
from on
on christmas uh
the best way to ensure we all have a
christmas as as close to normal as
possible
is to to to get on with uh with plan b
uh you know uh irritating though it may
be it is not a lockdown uh it is plan b
it is what we uh we set out uh a a while
back
and to get your get your boosters and
get your jabs that's the that's the best
way uh ford and as for when we'll review
the uh the the measures uh bear which i
think was your first your third point um
as i say no no later than early january
and possibly before uh if we start to
get some of that uh really really
granular uh information but you know
we need to we need to see the the data
and and work on it pretty hard
christmas parties and nativity
nativities yes sorry no no just do that
good good no they should not no so thank
you ben no uh in my view they should not
uh be uh they should follow the guidance
of course but we're not saying we don't
want uh kids to be taken out of school
before the end of term not that there's
a very long term to go now we don't want
nativity plays to be cancelled uh we
think that it's it's okay uh currently
on what we can see uh to
to keep going with uh with christmas
parties but obviously everybody should
exercise due
caution
have
ventilation wash your hands
get a a test before you go uh a sensible
thing to do uh give yourself uh we'll
give everybody else at the uh the party
the confidence that uh you know they're
going to be meeting uh someone who is
who is not contagious uh those are
simple things that people can do but
that's what we're uh that's what we're
saying
on the question you asked me um i think
it's far too early to be sure on this a
lot of scientists are doing a lot of
work at the moment just to work out what
uh the current two doses and different
combinations of those and the booster
will do with
the omicron variant
um and that will help give us some
information i think until then it's
probably not very helpful to speculate
the exception to that
is that there's a very small group but a
very important group of people who've
got significant immunosuppression who uh
we've get we're giving three doses to as
their primary course
they will then get a fourth dose which
is essentially their booster dose so in
that group the answer is yes but in the
great majority of people at this point i
think the answer is we'll have to wait
and see what the data show
just to build on that i mean
we've we've now got vaccine design that
allows you to alter them quite easily
and to make as chris said so called
multivalent or polyvalent vaccines
against different variants in one go
those are going to provide breadth of
coverage in the future when they'll be
needed we don't know
we've also got antiviral drugs coming
through now
uh two have been uh reported recently
which have good effects so there are
there are increasing number of options
to look at this but
this is important going back to the
timing point sage met last week and met
again last night yesterday
on both occasions saying that this is
spreading rapidly you don't just watch
it spreading rapidly you need to do
something and that isn't just the
boosters the boost is incredibly
important but it's also about trying to
reduce the possibility of spread
which means reducing social contacts in
order to try and achieve that
thank you emilia casalicchio from
politico
thanks prime minister um you just
suggested that uh simon case could
extend this probe beyond just this
alleged party on the 18th the the public
secretary for the department for
education today said that
that party that happened at dfe that
they apologized for will be included in
that probe so obviously it's quite
flexible so would you encourage simon
case to look at all allegations of all
parties that might have happened in
downing street last year and also would
you commit to the inquiry being
published before the end of the year how
quickly would you like to see it done
yeah and then i've got a question for
the scientists maybe all three of you um
obviously just announced new
restrictions including a recommendation
from work to work from home
is the fact that we're here
doing this now not a mark of failure
we should have fixed the roof while the
sun was shining surely with the pandemic
prepare the vaccine booster roll out so
it could have been done at lightning
speed but instead it's been quite slow
to get this this new part of the rollout
sorted
actually created a proper world beating
test and trace system but it feels like
we're still not quite there yet as well
we went through devastation last year
but it feels like we still haven't
completely learned our lessons and when
are we gonna learn because next time we
might be hit by virus that's much more
dangerous than the pandemic so are we
going to be actually ready by then
right well look i mean just can't go
emilia can i just go back on uh some of
the things you you've just said i i
think it's worth people bearing in mind
that there are a lot of countries
in our immediate neighborhood that have
got restrictions already far tougher
than ours and tougher than the ones that
we're asking uh people to implement now
much tougher and i think people should
always should also bear and that's
because we had the fastest vaccine
rollout in europe emilio just to to
remind you that and uh it is also the
case so far from uh having a a sluggish
uh vaccine rollout uh
what we've now got is i think 21 million
people uh having this a booster right
we've got 21 million people boosted and
again i think i'm right in saying uh
that whether
we we've boosted uh more people than any
uh comparable country and certainly
faster than any other european country
so i'm not going to hear any uh a
criticism of the nhs or the gps or uh or
the or the pharmacists or the volunteers
or everybody who's worked blindingly
hard to to get this done as fast as they
as they possibly can uh yes i think what
is abs well what i think is fair emilio
is to say that we now need to go much
further and much faster
having you know asking people uh to to
make further sacrifices as as we are uh
with uh with plan b
we've got to step up that booster
campaign and it's got to uh it's it's
got to grow wings and uh we you know the
pledge uh that everybody uh over a team
will get to the offer of a of a booster
by the end of january i want to see us
deliver that and i want to see uh such a
huge rate of booster uh vaccination in
this country that if as i hope
the the boosters can hold uh
omicron
then uh we can get back uh to the road
uh that we were on that's that's what
we're trying to achieve and on your on
your other point about the cabinet
secretary as far as i'm concerned uh
he's got to get to the bottom of uh of
what he thinks is uh is appropriate and
and right but uh you know i repeat my my
view uh that um
uh the
to the best of my knowledge everything
i've been told
is that
the the rules were followed but if that
doesn't turn out to be the case then
there will be the appropriate uh the
appropriate sanctions
yes uh
as i said in the house today as soon as
possible would like first go on yes
actually want to add on the on the wider
one i mean
there are multiple points you put there
and i'll try and give a very brief
answer short version on pandemic of
course we have to plan ahead but
remember that every pandemic is
different the last pandemic that is as
bad as this one and like you can
certainly conceptualize uh very very bad
uh alternative ones because hiv it's
actually transmitted infection
completely different way you approach it
so the idea that somehow something you
just take off the shelf and that's your
pandemic plan
every single time you have to readjust
adjust it according to what you find
this is a very serious pandemic second
question second general point
is uh inevitably
there have been bumps and on the road
and things we would do differently if we
had done them again that's
obvious
but actually uh the idea that a new
variant which we knew was going to come
has been everyone's been accepting that
is somehow a failure i think is a
misunderstanding of the biology so
speaking as a doctor you expect problems
to occur when they occur you address
them scientifically and rapidly and if i
can just make one plea on behalf of my
colleagues who do the operational side
whether on the nhs or elsewhere
quite a lot of those i'll put this
mildly as i can quite a lot of those who
say isn't it ridiculous is going so
slowly have not got as much experience
of running national programs as maybe
they might want to have to make those
kind of comments uh actually these
things are difficult and i think the
people who are doing it are doing it
magnificently personally yeah well i
wanted to say exactly that there are two
things i'd pull out first of all i think
vaccines task force was foresighted to
make sure that we had enough boosters
for this winter wasn't inevitable that
we would need boosters and they got the
supply in advance ready to be able to do
that and i think the uh nhs rollout
involving people right the way across
the country has been one that we should
be proud of actually i think you know
it's an operational point not not a
science point for me but i think i look
at them and think they've done a great
job of getting that out and you look
across other countries and you'll see
the booster campaign here has been very
effective so i'd like to thank them for
everything they've done actually in
getting those out both of those groups
and then i'd like also to say that if
you look at the
100-day mission that we published at the
time of the g7 that was precisely about
trying to make sure all of the parts
from surveillance through to rapid
production of vaccines and therapeutics
through to
what needs to happen for finance and
getting this across the world and
equitable access
can be improved right the way across the
world
so that for any
new infection going forward there is a
road map to try and get this done more
quickly and more efficiently than was
possible this time and so i think making
sure that 100-day mission which the g7
endorsed is something that really is
taken up right the way across the world
is going to be crucially important
good thanks everybody thank you
there we are boris johnson ending that
news conference he was talking about the
spread of the new variant which was
rapid he said doubling every two to
three days there could be a big rise in
hospitalizations he said and deaths so
now is the time for plan b to buy time
to get more people boosted let's have a
look at the measures what uh was
announced plan b means that uh we'll
well we can expect stronger government
messaging on the increased level of risk
and the need for the public to behave
more cautiously but uh specifically
there will be mandatory coveted vaccine
passports in nightclubs and large venues
from
next week face coverings will also
become a legal requirement in most
public indoor settings including
theaters and cinemas but not bars and
restaurants that from friday and the
guidance is that people should work from
home
if they can
from
monday
uh deputy political editor sam coates
was listening to all that so sam some
big announcements uh
there but the questions certainly
overshadowed by this whole issue of the
christmas parties
that's right britain england enters plan
b so those four points uh from friday
when it comes to masks from monday when
it comes to working from home couple of
key concessions from the prime minister
uh he said that for vaccine passports
which you're going to have to show to
get into venues you can get in there if
you also show a lateral flow also you
had to isolate previously uh if you came
into contract with somebody with omicron
now boris johnson said if you test every
day you don't have to isolate if you
come into contact with somebody from
omicron so mixed picture but we've been
monitoring over in the commons what
sanjay javid the health secretary has
been saying he said that there are 568
omicron cases but the real number of
infections because we only test and
discover a proportion of them is likely
to be 20 times that so we could have at
the moment in this country ten thousand
omicron cases uh and he expects that
there will be a million cases of omicron
by the end of the week tory mp's unhappy
with some of the measures particularly
vaccine passports that the government
are talking about introducing sanjay
javid was actually heckled when he
suggested that the government is poised
to bring those things in back in the
press conference you just heard from the
prime minister he said that the large
numbers of unvaccinated people may mean
that we have to extend the vaccine
passport
system
which will require people to show that
they've been jabbed or had a negative
test if the problem continues there'll
be a national conversation needed about
that otherwise the prime minister pretty
much sticking to his line
on the downing street party whether it
took place said it was a matter of a
simon case the cabinet secretary to
investigate chris whittie pleaded with
the country uh said that people might be
angry over what's happened but still
they have to follow the restrictions uh
so scientists very much aware of the
politics that's been going on today but
trying to make it clear that people
should follow the rules nevertheless
okay sam thanks very much indeed so the
main measures work from home from monday
if you can from friday face marks in
most face masks in most public indoor
venues including theaters and cinemas
and coved passports will come in at some
stage for big events we'll have much
more on this at the top of the hour and
that will be
with dermot monahan
[Music]